[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today even how
can we
help oh hi hi guys thanks for taking the
call you bet what's going on so I'm
looking for some advice uh uh we just me
and my wife just recently uh got on the
Ramy plan we're on baby step two um I'm
a full-time High School
teacher um and I've taken uh taking a
part-time EMS job when I'm out on on
vacation and uh the weekends and stuff
and I do some food delivery uh to try to
just pack as much money as we can to
this debt wow but I'm AF I'm
afraid that um my wife's getting
overwhelmed by it
so because you're not home what's going
on man you're pretty emotional right now
what are you
feeling I just I you know it's like a
baby Christian you know I don't want to
I don't want to be so intense that she's
like oh you know you won't let us do
anything and and this and that what's
going on I don't know how to have that
that conversation say well take us to
what's going on with you guys
relationally what what are you feeling
from her what are you hearing from her
that you would call us about
this well um it like like uh for
instance she works full-time at home we
have two kids okay and um so when I'm
like all right I'm going to go a goal to
make $50 a day with food delivery okay
um five days a week so that's extra
$1,000 a month and then on uh Saturdays
I go work this EMS job which are 24-hour
shifts oh man and that's extra $360 each
day I do that and then but she still
like well you think you can stay home
tonight so that uh you know we can clean
the house and get ready for our
Christmas brunch that's coming up and
and um I don't I I
I I I I I'm like well you think that
maybe you you know you could pick up a
little bit of that so that we can
continue to stay on plan okay I see
what's going on here yeah and then I get
kind of negative feedback well you know
well so now we just you're not here to
help around in the house and stuff like
that and I let me ask a couple
clarifying questions when you said she
works full-time does she work full-time
as a stay-at-home mom or does she work
full-time at a job that is work from
home yeah job that work from home okay
but there the are also there too so that
kind of falls on her as well right when
when they're not in school like right
now we're on Christmas break I totally
get that okay and then can you tell me
how much debt do you guys have because
I'm trying to understand I mean I get
the intensity but I want to I just want
to get a bigger picture Okay so uh we
have about uh uh
$226,000 in uh cars and uh credit cards
break it down which what's the cars and
what's the credit cards uh my wife's
cars almost paid off it's got 3,000 left
my trucks got 11,000 left and then we
have uh about 15,000 in credit cards
okay and then um another 10,000 around
that that I owe to my uh to my
mother-in-law my what's the payoff date
if you didn't miss any night scheduled
you've got this thing figured out if you
stay on this pace what do you anticipate
the day would be how far in the future
before you pay off this debt I I I I I
told my wife we can do it in six months
not our house I I have house sure sure
sure sure so let me just tell you hey so
Stephen so manto man here uh I love this
intensity but U there this is a
six-month window it'd be different if
this were a six-year and you guys had to
be that intense I love the intensity I
think you have to downshift in moments
like this when your wife is giving you
the signal you read it man you've been
married long enough you know uh going
after it but but if there's a holiday
party in the situation you gave us I
think the answer and this is not
criticism you called so I'm going to
tell you as a dude just my take here in
that situation uh you take the night off
from gazelle intensity and you jump in
and help her out I I think if you guys
were in much bigger debt and it were far
more intense I think there's a
conversation to be had to say hey babe I
got to do this we got to be all in but I
think given this situation I don't think
this is three or four nights a week I
think you sit down with her and go hey
I'm doing this to Sprint hang in there
but if you need you need that kind of
emergency situation raise your hand and
I'm going to be more sensitive next time
and I'll jump in that would be my take
in this situation what's you guys's
combined income yearly you mentioned all
the things you're doing but what does
that amount
to uh so that's recent the uh the EMS
job and stuff but so right now we make
about 110 gross together just at our
regular jobs m and I'm looking to bring
in uh I I got plan to bring in 3,000
extra a month so uh about 30,000 more so
maybe about 140,000 if I stay on this
track okay so you're basically saying
our normal budget stays the same and I'm
side hustling to pay off I get it that
caused a little tral too because then we
stripped the budget way down as well we
cut off some streaming services well
that's what I'm saying it it it almost
needs to be one or the other because
you've got $39,000 of debt and you just
outlined a plan where your side Hustle
to bring in an extra almost
40,000 so if the side hustling alone is
paying off the debt then like I'm trying
to find a way where you guys can balance
this out a little bit a little bit more
does that make sense because if you okay
yeah I understand if if you're going to
bring in $40,000 a year and this is a a
full year play as opposed to you just
trying to like to Ken's point just
squeak this thing out in six months I do
think that you
know if you can get her on board fine
but like Ken said you know if she's
having these moments where she's
throwing a flag on the play like listen
we haven't seen you we don't we don't
even remember what you look like dude
like you do have to you have to cool out
for a minute right and I think that um I
think there's room for you to take the
pedal off the metal just a little bit
yeah right great because I don't want to
burn her out so I so I guess that's what
I looking for to say your instincts are
right yeah she's like a baby bird
sometimes you got to get them to keep
keep coming to you I think your
instincts are right you called us we're
validating your instincts your instincts
are right you're pushing really hard and
it's affecting her and you don't want to
lose her and and in the midst of this
cause the cause is not as important as
as her and the kids right because it's
not at that point what's the point
especially during this that's right but
listen my man she seems to be all in we
heard no signs of her not being all in
it's just hey we got a holiday party and
I'm swamp with the kids and I'm
exhausted you know I also think it's
important for you to uh show some
appreciation to her for her being all in
and you know what maybe take a night uh
coming up in the next couple weeks and
totally surprise her and say hey babe
here's a little money that I've been
making on the side hustle go out with
some of your best girlfriends have a
nice night I'll take care of the kids
all right Ken Coleman do you know I mean
what do you think Jade I think that's a
teamwork play that's a teamwork play cuz
she's listen I'm just I'm honoring all
the moms out there my wife has has has
done both Stacy has fluctuated between
being a work out of the home and a work
in the home notice I say work in the
home because that's a lot of work and
there are times where it's really good
guys for us to just
acknowledge uh the partner in the
situation and uh and say hey you know
what I appreciate you being on board
show some love here is when you're going
at that pace you have to ahead of time
say what the Milestones are going to be
when we pay off this car we get this
when we do this and it sounds like like
they don't have those milestones in
place and that is so important you need
like a cheat day you know these big time
athletes like I I follow the rock no big
deal you know I like cheat meals have
you seen the man's cheat meals it's
pretty fantastic so even one of the
greatest athletes actors you know get
after it guys in the world you got those
down days I think mama needs a little
little little time off every once a
while and you can fund that and then we
keep going with great momentum Stephen
you're a good man and a good husband
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life